in many ways the response from Nashville
police to the mass shooting by trans
terrorists at a Christian School here in
town has been admirable that starts of
course with their physical response
their emergency response to the shooting
itself yesterday we saw the the
harrowing body cam footage a group of
officers obviously well-trained highly
skilled
made their way into the building
clearing rooms as they went eventually
confronting the shooter and quickly
dispatching her and neutralizing the
threat now we greatly overused the term
hero these days just like we overuse so
many other terms effectively rendering
the labels meaningless and that's a
shame because it's it's a term that
would actually apply in this case to
those cops they are in every sense
Heroes but then after the shooting they
continued to um the police did continue
to handle the situation with great
transparency and forthrightness the
police chief has been direct and clear
clear with his answers during his press
conferences they released the body cam
footage they released the security
camera footage of the shooting the
shooter entering the building
they've provided a lot of information
but there is one glaring omission and
it's an Omission that becomes all the
more glaring considering how transparent
they've been about everything else
the trans shooter wrote a detailed
Manifesto and we know about that because
the cops told us apparently explaining
what she was going to do what her plans
were and why she was doing it
they have not allowed us to see the
manifesto
a couple of days later we still have not
seen the manifesto and according to
reports yesterday we may never see it
this is from The Daily Caller quote
Nashville police will not be releasing
the manifesto of the deceased Covenant
School shooting suspect a police
spokesperson told the Daily Caller news
foundation on Tuesday Nashville Metro
Police Department announced that they
had found writings from 28 year old
transgender suspect Audrey Hale's home
on Monday that indicated a calculated
and planned attack according to an uh
nmpd press release the police
spokesperson told the dcnf Tuesday that
the department had no intentions of
releasing the documents to the public
anytime soon citing the ongoing
investigation into hail quote no we will
not be released in the manifesto during
an open investigation the spokesperson
said the police spokesperson did not say
for certain whether or not the manifesto
would be released in the future after
the investigation was closed and
restated that due to the ongoing nature
of the situation there was no intention
by law enforcement to release the
documents
well this is just completely
unacceptable and also incoherent they're
investigating a crime committed by a
dead assailant and the person is
thankfully dead that there's no
conceivable reason at least not any
valid conceivable reason why that
investigation would be impeded by
allowing the public to see
these documents
okay and if I can't even imagine what it
would be but if there are a couple of
things in there that for some reason it
would if if we if that was published it
would impede the investigation then you
could talk about redacting certain
elements of it now even redacting the
documents
can be highly problematic
but my point is they're saying we can't
see any of it we can't see even a single
line of it
and that doesn't make any sense
we have a right to know why this
happened
now the why seems rather obvious but we
should also see it laid out in writing
if it was and apparently it was
and we have a right to know what or who
the other targets were supposed to be
we can either just like with anything
else we can either be left to speculate
in the dark
or we can be given the full truth and as
we've seen time and time again the
speculating in the dark option doesn't
help anyone
and we know that because this is the
option that the powers that be uh so
often choose
now when I say it doesn't help anyone
maybe I shouldn't say that because uh
what I mean is that it doesn't help the
public it doesn't serve the best
interests of the community it's not good
for society when vital truths are
withheld from us leaving us to speculate
and assume and come up with theories
but in this case it does serve the
interests of LGBT activist groups who
are actually actively campaigning to
prevent the public from ever seeing the
manifesto Newsweek reports quote calls
for police to release the manifesto that
authorities say was written ahead of
Monday's Nashville Nashville school
shooting has prompted concern among
lgbtq plus groups who caution against
the publication of such a document quote
it should not be published Jordan Budd
the executive director of children of
lesbians and gays everywhere told
Newsweek the focus should be on how this
was able to happen in the first place
there should not be such easy access to
deadly weaponry
Charles Moran the national president of
Log Cabin Republicans a GOP organization
that advocates for equal rights for
lgbtq plus Americans also told Newsweek
that there are serious consequences for
the public release of the manifesto
Laura McGinnis a spokesperson for pflag
agreed telling Newsweek that um
publication on these documents would
increase the risk of contagion she said
that while the manifesto would help a
law enforcement and policymakers
identify potential warning signs to
prevent future tragedies ultimately the
contents don't change the outcome of the
tragedy
quote regardless of the shooter's
intentions the real issue here is the
ease of access to deadly weapons in
Tennessee and elsewhere Bud said adding
quote all children no matter who their
parents are or how they identify should
feel safe and supported at school that
includes a world free from gun violence
now you'll notice uh shockingly that
these LGBT groups are mysteriously
silent about these kinds of concerns
after shootings by white supremacists
I mean they're more than happy for those
manifestos to be published and they
always are
but in this case they caution against it
the only mildly surprising thing about
this is that they they haven't really
bothered to come up with a plausible
excuse for this glaring inconsistency
and hypocrisy instead they essentially
confess to the truth they want the
discussion around the shooting to remain
focused on a politically useful issue
like gun control don't tell us why this
happened they cry uh you know that'll
make it more difficult for us to use the
tragedy for political gain
most of all they're desperate to protect
their victim narrative this is their
most potent political weapon and uh more
than that it is the foundation of their
entire ideology
they must protect at all costs the
hallucinatory notion that LGBT people
and in particular trans people are
oppressed and marginalized and you know
they're the ones being targeted not the
other way around
a Manifesto full of anti-christian
ramblings from a trans-terrorist
psychopath would be a powerful counter
example to this idea
so powerful that they can't allow it to
see the light of day
of course even without the manifesto we
still have the simple and terrible fact
that a trans Mass killer slaughtered
children at a Christian school that's
all we need to know or all we should
need to know
yet the left helped helped Along by the
lack of transparency around the
manifesto is still clinging to its
preferred victim narrative
they insist that even though a trans
person murdered Christian children
the real victims are trans people this
seems to be the consensus as you might
expect on Tick Tock watch
so about the tragic school shooting that
happened today at a private Christian
School in Tennessee
um the shooter was born a biological
female and they went by he him on their
LinkedIn so they're they're painting The
Narrative that you know they're trying
to blame transgender people you know the
whole thing but every other school
shooting that's happened in the last I
don't know decade have been white men
and many of them identify as Christians
so let's not go there but I do want to
say that expect more of this kind of
chaos and destruction when you bring
fascism into this country the more you
don't love people the more you shame
people the more you treat people like
they're Untouchable in society what do
you expect people to do of course the
the shadow inside of them is going to be
so angry and retaliate in Revenge that's
what happens when you decide tried to
try to control people through
legislation you try to harm people
through legislation
it's like
the world needs a lot more love not more
hate
no uh first of all all of the School
shooters for the last decade have not
been white men and as for your question
what do we expect people to do
what do we expect what do we expect a
trans person to do if she's upset about
not being affirmed or whatever
what do we expect well um we expect her
to not murder children
let's start there
that is a basic standard of behavior
that we hold everyone to it's not even
the bare minimum I mean that is a bar so
low that it's still sitting on the
ground we expect her to refrain from
killing nine-year-olds we expect you
know a lot more from people actually but
yes we do expect to begin with that they
act like human beings and not murderous
demons
this has been the prevailing message on
the left yesterday we uh we talked about
a group of trans activists called the
trans resistance Network who published a
statement claiming that the shooter was
a victim of her own shooting they
lamented that quote life for transgender
people is very difficult and made more
difficult in the preceding months by a
virtual Avalanche of anti-trans
legislation and they reason that she
felt that she she had to commit the
shooting in order to quote be seen
now um
according to these people also the
shooter's problems are compounded by the
fact that she's being posthumously
misgendered along with perhaps the
greater problem that she's burning in
hell but uh but along with that she's
being misgendered here's Tick Tock again
Eden hail that's the name of the
Nashville shooter this video is about to
be very uncomfortable for a lot of us
it's very uncomfortable for me to talk
about but we need to talk about it Aiden
did a very horrendous thing period Point
Blank we need pew pew reform in our
country but the way that the media and
the police are misgendering and dead
naming Aiden is quite concerning it's
also concerning that I had to go to the
telegraph from UK to actually get
Aiden's chosen name It's upsetting that
constantly it is she her pronouns that
is incredibly frustrating because even
though they did this horrible thing does
not mean that we get to to do those
things that's a boundary and we can hold
people accountable without being
transphobic even for some of the most
horrendous things so while you're
watching this also watch for transphobia
because it's very clearly coming out
you know uh just to be clear uh her dead
name is Audrey because she's dead thank
God so really they're both her dead
names I guess
yeah she says that uh even though the
shooter murdered children that doesn't
mean that we get to use grammatically
correct pronouns in reference to her
well actually it does in fact we get to
use grammatically correct pronouns about
people even if they don't commit mass
shootings
the mass shooting gives us permission to
say lots of other things about her that
she was a monstrous bloodthirsty
murdering worthless piece of garbage for
example but as for the pronouns we get
to uh do that regardless
actually listen to this check this out
that this is going to shock you
we get to say whatever we want
to or about her or you or anyone else
that's what we get to do
what you don't get to do is control our
words or our minds
I can say whatever I want about anyone
and I will and I can say whatever I want
about any trans person and I will they
do not get to dictate anything to me
that's what they don't get to do
I talk about them according to how I see
them and what I think about them
and according to what is actually true
I don't talk about them according to how
they see themselves I am using the
filter of my own mind
and of reality I am not using the filter
of their minds
that's the way that this works
but the shooter herself isn't the only
trans victim here according to the left
there have been many headlines like this
from ABC quote anti-transgender
sentiment follows Nashville shooting
conservative political figures focused
on the shooter's reported trans identity
and This from NBC fear pervades
Tennessee's trans Community amid focus
on Nashville Shooters gender identity
and here's a bit from that NBC article
says within 10 minutes of police saying
that the suspect was transgender the
hashtag trans-terrorism trended on
Twitter around the same time Republican
lawmakers including Senator JD Vance and
conservative Firebrand representative
Marjorie Taylor green insinuated in
social media posts that the shooter's
gender identity played a role in the
shooting well no that wasn't the well
they may have insinuated but actually
began with the police chief who who
strongly suggested that
um anyway it says and by Tuesday Morning
the cover of the Rupert Murdoch owned
New York Post Red quote transgender
killer targets Christian School
well yeah because that's what happened
oh so so apparently what we're learning
here is the New York Post had a headline
that's just accurate I mean that's
exactly what happened
quote we're terrified for the lgbtq
community here Kim spoon a trans
activist based in Knoxville Tennessee
said more blood's going to be shed and
it's not going to be shed in a school
Denise Sadler drag performer who's
transgender said that she had already
hired four armed guards before Monday's
shooting to secure a drag show that
she's hosting at a gay bar in Nashville
this weekend she with uh Big Air quotes
around that by the way following the
anti-trans rhetoric spawned by the
shooting Sadler said quote unquote she
is not planning to hire eight
you don't know if the shooter's gender
identity is going to trigger a community
of people who already hated us to come
and try to shoot us to prove a point
Sadler said at the end of the day
there's a lot of hurt going on there's a
lot of anger going on there's a lot of
confusion going on aisling Bailey the
acting president of Tri-Cities
transgender a trans LED support and
advocacy group based in Johnson City
Tennessee said that her quote unquote
her initial reaction to news the suspect
was transgender Was Fear
I knew that as soon as anyone mentioned
that it was immediately going to become
the center Focus instead of what should
be the focus and that's gun violence in
this country Bailey said
well that really sums it up doesn't it
that sums it up six innocent people were
massacred and the first thought the
first thought
the first thing that he thought about uh
the first thing this transactus thought
about was how this would affect him
his very first thought was concerned for
himself
after hearing that three children and
three School staff members were murdered
forget about the fact that the fears
make no sense okay trans terrorism
should be a cause of concern for those
of us who oppose the trans movement not
for Trans people themselves
and even aside from that the narcissism
is once again the point
always points back to that this is a
movement of self-worship and
self-obsession a movement full of people
who cannot see beyond themselves people
who cannot see the rest of the world do
not acknowledge the existence really of
other human beings
because they're constantly staring in
the mirror even if it is oftentimes more
of a fun house mirror
constantly staring back into their own
egos obsessed with their own emotions
and their own need for affirmation
that is what we learn here
though it is a lesson that we've already
learned many times
that'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block you
can become a member today and use code
wall should check out for two months
free on all annual plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]